it costs about ten thousand dollars a
month buddy you're who you I have I have
grown children there's 12 months in a
year that's 120 000.
ten thousand dollars a month it costs
ten thousand dollars I mean
I know it costs fruit for your baby to
have a room a bed
a school a ride to school food to eat at
school
it costs ten thousand dollars a month
my kids living well
depending on what happens with this kid
that you're expecting we might want to
walk back that figure a little to maybe
like three thousand dollars a month in
case they come at you for child support
no I'm not worried about that
I'm not worried about no I'm not worried
about that because
I've made her good enough to use her
she's good she can use her name anywhere
and get anything she she wants she
doesn't need you know
so I'm not making her dependent